an object is moving along a line the
following graph gives the object's
velocity over time
for each point on the graph is the
object moving forward backward or
neither so pause this video and see if
you can figure that out
all right now let's do this together and
so we can see these different points on
this velocity versus time graph and the
important thing to realize is is if the
velocity is positive we're moving
forward if the velocity is negative
we're moving backward and if the
velocity is zero we're not moving
either forward nor backwards or neither
forward nor backwards so right over here
we see that our velocity is positive
it's a positive two meters per second so
that means that we are
moving forward
now over here our velocity is zero
meters per second so this is
neither
now over here our velocity is negative
four meters per second so one way to
think about it is we're moving four
meters per second backwards
so i'll write backward
now this is interesting this last point
because you might be tempted to say all
right i'm oscillating i'm going up then
i'm going down then i'm going back up
maybe i'm moving forward here but
remember what we're thinking about here
this isn't position versus time this is
velocity versus time so if our velocity
is negative we're moving backwards and
here e our velocity is still negative
it's becoming less negative but it's
still negative so we are still
moving
we are still moving backward if we were
at this point right over here
or at this point then we would be moving
forward if our velocity were positive